reading some podcasts Ville kick this
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] listen we got one of those
experimental shows today we talked a
little bit we do a little zoom with Dean
del Rey and then you go on your [ __ ]
way okay but we start Monday on a
[ __ ] tremendous note it's a beautiful
day to be alive thank you very much for
[ __ ] tuning into the church we're
still here
I got the mask on per [ __ ] orders cuz
you know you can't leave the house how
to make a call one of my soldiers
[ __ ] say where did you get this mask
you know that's no questions they just
give them to you that's it
I've been very fortunate I also wear
bandana but you gotta be careful but
that's it with the fear of this [ __ ]
what's up with you bad [ __ ] I
hope you're hanging in there
I've been posting movies free every day
I've been posting music you know I'm
trying my hardest here guys I'm not
gonna make a video every day and jump up
and down I don't need the attention that
much my whole wall thing is to make sure
you guys a tip top Magoo before I even
[ __ ] start with him before we tag
into dean del rey this is my week i had
a rough night Wednesday night watching
the [ __ ] mechanic come on oh my own
business the original mechanic was on
from the [ __ ] beginning I'm like okay
this seems like this is gonna work let
me watch it for a little while it was
great
can we talk about this last night we're
talking about with Dean for a second oh
we talked about with Dean I watched the
[ __ ] mechanic and damn at the end
that real wise [ __ ] Jan Michael Vincent
wasn't too [ __ ] good in this movie
I've been Carlos you ever see after this
was a really good thrown punches but
then they run and you lose all the faith
in him he had a run one time I'm like
this guy runs like a [ __ ] like a
queen with a pick up his ass you just
noticed it now a couple guys do that you
know Jax tower I love them to death
sons of anarchy don't make them run
don't make him run Steven Seagal was
great until he started running once
those people like that gotta run and you
see how they run they're like what
happened who taught that don't they did
in Russia they teach you how to run you
missing the Agostino wife she runs
perfectly she she's so beautiful she's
even prettier when she
runs she [ __ ] holes I hide up high in
the back they teach you how to run in
[ __ ] Russia
it'll teach you how to run here nah let
you get chased by the cops you don't
learn nobody teaches how to run
correctly unless you join the school
track team or some [ __ ] like that let's
say you know you've seen those things a
lot of times like I don't know what
happened I do know what happened but I
don't know what happened I hate I hadn't
eaten that about in about a week I had
been drinking those [ __ ] juices just
to switch it up a little bit because
your body builds a tolerance and they
two of those ABX tablets and I was just
writing and I wasn't thinking about my
future I dug into my past and I thought
about certain things I had done and you
know toppled us what's going on today
and everything around me and not having
the ability to [ __ ] go do your
[ __ ] job anymore go do comedy I know
I just went into a dark [ __ ] place
well then just saw myself as a child
doing the stupid [ __ ] I was doing up to
the age before I got pregnant and guilt
I was overrun by guilt and once you get
guilt and [ __ ] anxiety and everything
mixed up you create a [ __ ] grenade so
grenade went off in my mind then Donna
didn't show up at your house naked and
shoot your whole family thank God we saw
Lee I'm scared him one day I'm just
gonna [ __ ] in my hand and throw it at
somebody I realized that the 20 years a
drug use was [ __ ] terrible but I
thought about something well I was
sitting there going through this [ __ ]
mental breakdown that my wife was in the
other room and two rooms a room next to
her my daughter was narrow like the way
I've been sitting in here hiding from my
[ __ ] wife I need her now more than
ever you know when out there and I sat
with her we probably talked to like
[ __ ] 11:30 at night just about what
was going on in my head what was going
on in her head and I gotta taste him the
house
been a hundred and fifty percent better
you know yeah do I still get shitty
moments we're all gonna have shitty days
you know and this is just hot we're
halfway there
we're at the three three week mark we're
complaining we're at three weeks we
still have three and we don't even know
if they're gonna add two more those
three so all you can do is write you
know but Joey I'll have a punching bag I
know you got two arms [ __ ] uh what do
you call that when you [ __ ] shadowbox
you know that it's it's you gotta
fulfill [ __ ] 16 hours a day you know
now so you have a little work to do from
the office somebody's aren't working but
the most important thing you got I mean
it's so hard now because not only do you
have to take care of your immune system
but you have to watch your mental right
now this is gonna really [ __ ] with
people's mental right now so please if
you're feeling robots who BOTS or
whatever the [ __ ] you're feeling right
now you know pick up the phone call your
relatives call some people it's not you
this is not you you're not going crazy
the world [ __ ] took a [ __ ] and this
is what's going on right now because of
it it has nothing to do with you so you
see yourself starting to get [ __ ]
whatever I don't want you to call I
don't want you to go to a psychiatrist
not only go to a [ __ ] just call a
friend talk to a friend you know what
send me a message type type while you're
typing your breathing and whatever is in
your heart will come out all right guys
it's rough for everybody but we're all
gonna make it through this is the
[ __ ] church with a [ __ ] United
States of America we're gonna make it
through
we don't [ __ ] play games here now
without further ado I'm gonna have Dean
come on I'm gonna talk for a little
while and then I'll come back on we'll
wrap it up and I'll put you out there in
your way so when you get out there today
nothing it's nothing's gonna be
different you're gonna be a better
person you're gonna be a little kind of
the people you gonna show humanity
listen nobody's got done what you think
you're special you're the only one
that's going through this everybody's
going through something right now
imagine having a loved
one in the nursing home or anything and
they think anything could be possible
right now so keep your eyes open keep
your head up and keep your head clear
don't let any bad thoughts go into it
like I did the other day and uh nearly
[ __ ] short-circuited me well me how
before we go I mean I know you talked to
your wife but how did you talk yourself
down from them with that ledge like I've
talked myself off for 200 other ledges
you know I'm not everybody thinks that
they're special it they're the only ones
who have problems everybody's got mental
issues and these mental issues expand
they get a little bigger with all this
[ __ ] going on this is too much for most
people to handle this is more than a lot
of people handle their whole life not
having a job not being able to go to
work throw a funeral for a loved one and
you know this is too much for us to
handle this is too much for our
circuitry to handle at one time you know
okay so there's a virus okay now I lost
my job okay now I can get unemployment
on the phone okay right now cousin mildy
died okay you know there's too many
things and all I'm I'm just I'm just
trying to [ __ ] and smooth it out the
humps in the bumps when you get to that
part where you feel that here spinning
out you got to open up you got to go on
front of your house
find your own safe place maybe do a
little breathing a lot of breathing this
a lot of breathing guys a lot of
breathing exercises here this is you
could feel the stress in your neck you
could feel at times I can feel it and
I'm not applying for unemployment you
know I applied for a small loan whatever
small business loan because you have to
but besides that I didn't it's not like
I got a [ __ ] I gotta have to pay this
on the 15th or my lights are gonna be
shut down you know like I told you two
weeks ago and I'm reinforcing it today I
spoken to for people that got landlord
told him to go [ __ ] themselves didn't
give a [ __ ] what the mayor got said he
said so like I told you I told you guys
in the beginning I've been in these
situations before
in the world you know in these
situations it doesn't get better by them
making it better it gets better by you
making it better and one thing about you
is don't be a sucker
tomorrow the movie of the day Monday
today Monday the 6th of April the movie
of the day is to live and die in LA and
there's a line in that movie that I'll
never forget and it's John Turturro
telling the [ __ ] guy when he visits
him in jail they visit John in jail I
forget the name of the lead actor he
also played the temptation of Christ the
foe will him default goes to meet John
Turturro in the jail and he goes don't
worry about nothing I'm gonna get you an
attorney and I'll get Charlie in a
couple days and John Tudor looks when he
goes yeah right and I promise check-in
is in the mail and I promise not to come
in your mouth ok I told you guys in the
beginning this ain't gonna be what
they're telling you the check is not
gonna miraculous peer like the Bluebird
of happiness you know nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you know you have to assume
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
so before you sit there and say I didn't
know I told you [ __ ] three weeks
ago that this government these checks
ain't coming in for a while you got to
assume they don't come in there like
they're like it's like when you go to
Dairy Queen and you get a sundae on top
of it you got to keep doing what you're
doing because if not the [ __ ] [ __ ]
four walls are gonna shut down on you
this check is gonna come some time
whatever you don't have no problem no
control over that or you could do is
survive today how am I gonna make it
happen today do I gotta go unload a
truck plate do I gotta go to burn a
building today a lot of people looking
for us and this arsonist is big right
now everybody is looking for us and this
right now to burn down to business
anyway
let's go on to Dean Del Ray and do this
little podcast for you I hope you enjoy
it
it's our first Zune Dean where are you
coming to you live from the truck from
the cab of the truck what is up my
brother hey you look good last night on
TV [ __ ]
all your life you gonna act in classes
and nothing now they need you on TV how
are you man I gotta have the mask on
it's the law
you got a [ __ ] obey the law when I
teenagers no more deen dayal resi
what have you been doing with this whole
[ __ ] sorry to come out here with this
zoom [ __ ] but I guess this is the future
for now I never believed in this I like
live podcast and [ __ ] so I could
see your eyes but we got to bring Dean
Delray to the Masters you know I'm
saying it's all my doing show I don't
care if it's audio video or just shoot
the [ __ ] the hard way I'm I'm in the
Joey Diaz what have you been up to these
last couple weeks going crazy you know
going crazy I mean I'm not being a heart
I got no internet my Internet's down and
I don't want the guy to come over you
know because I know it's like STDs
really performing you know it's a it's a
different time because you really don't
know who's coming over I knew and you
don't want you I don't want to even take
the [ __ ] chance you know yeah thank
God we got music Dean cuz I'll tell you
it is [ __ ] kept me alive these last
couple weeks
oh it's it's on 24/7 brother at the
house 20 point that I never had TV
before so to me and I'm an only child so
I'm not going to crazy but I miss the
gym you know like I got that diabetes
like three years ago four years ago
coming up there
I've been gym every day and now I'm just
like wow I made my house like I'm like
glad that dude on Toxie De Niro in taxi
I just didn't they're getting ready
- Oh work off you know when I lived up
the corner the kid downstairs one into
the Navy and he was a personal trainer
so he said listen she's gonna sell that
[ __ ] cuz they broke up and she goes at
this something you want just take it I
took a couple 15 pound dumbbells I took
one of those weighted balls and he had a
not a swinging punch bag but the other
ones and as soon as as soon as this
thing started I started hitting that bag
because I know that when you read up
about you know and benefits of boxing
benefits of Muay Thai they always say
that striking gets to stress out so that
at least I have that to keep me alive
thank God for honor and I got a couple
kettlebells
I got some club bells and I'm just
trying to stay active that way you know
I don't want to go to a park and walk
behind somebody who's you know
everybody's walking the same way at the
park so I'm just behind 20 people suck
in 20 people's germs so it doesn't make
sense as you can see I got the mass but
I got vitamin D bound I'm out there all
day in the Sun well the divided be
[ __ ] you needed big for this Corona
it's just like when I'm in New York City
there in the craziest city gone and
they're attached they're not even
watching these guys I was walking
walking right into the virus you know
yeah no no looking at this screen i I've
taken this seriously again because of
our age you got to take this seriously
and one thing I've noticed that the
first off as a as a state when number
four right now yeah this is working us
not going out and doing dumb [ __ ] is
definitely [ __ ] working you know I'm
gonna keep doing it I don't give a [ __ ]
you know I've been to prison
I know how to [ __ ] make the best tell
you know and and jerking off gonna do
nothing for you
you can't jerk off you want to bang one
out in the shower that's fine but you
can't do like when you were in prison
you jerk off every eight hours every
three hours because it's gonna kill
eight minutes every minute is [ __ ]
valuable this time you know I got a
certain distance I travel around I don't
need out you know when Lee told me he
wasn't he nod I'm like that's it the
world's got to be going up cuz if my boy
won't go for a [ __ ] topo or something
if he said I haven't had a cheeseburger
in three weeks if he has a cheeseburger
a week he's losing it but I just saw
this I got an email this morning and
I'll tell you who's got a [ __ ] pretty
decent deal Ruth Chris is selling me
smart they're selling ten ounce
hamburgers pre-made four bucks yeah you
know that's not a bad deal you know a
couple dollars Ruth Chris I trust Ruth's
Chris you know my brother might nieces
fiance works for them and she told me
what they're doing and how they're doing
it they use in three cooks two managers
they're staying open
I still haven't tried it but once I got
this email for food they're selling and
they even called my wife said they
called about a week ago because we had a
ton of points left oh yeah I had a bunch
of points people gave me cards and [ __ ]
and they were like they got expire so
we're like we'll be there this week you
can't sit there and eat but you could
take it I'm craving sushi like a
[ __ ]
oh I didn't go for a piece of albacore
right now I would kill that happy hour
over at sushi dance
they're lucky he's not getting as he was
eating that sushi no I don't trust
anything he was he was buying direct
from a fisherman and woman I probably
had the coronavirus to be honest I think
you did a lot of people had the virus
already and
own it a girl told me she thinks she got
it in January but who gives a [ __ ] about
the virus or some what have you been
spinning what have you discovered that
has blown your mind with music oh man
okay I think now let's see where King
Buffalo some friends of mine I had him
on the show about a year ago
three guys three-piece band they just
put out a new record last Friday and
this [ __ ] thing is devastating man
appearing but like two entire sand
desert rock this thing is unreal man
they took it to another level so that
thing was on for a week straight up my
house I mean neighbors are probably
going crazy man I know you will listen
to a new Pearl Jam which is good thank
you for the recommendation yeah Eddie
Vetter did it again
so I've been listening to that it's
funny man I've been listening to uh to a
lot of old albums like I come in here
some nights I came in here the other
night with my wife when we [ __ ] scrub
the carpets and then her in the baby
left and I stayed here and that I just
listened to a couple of arms and it's so
weird that music is the soundtrack of
our lives you know I've had some ups and
downs over the last couple of weeks the
hardest night I had was probably
Wednesday night last week where
everything was accepted you know the the
coronavirus the fall of stand up my past
my sins you know everything came to
whatever I had a little mini nervous
breakdown but I made it out all right
thank God for edibles and thank God for
edibles but music has really kept it
together for me and I and I thank you a
lot because you've returned me on to a
lot of those albums I've been going full
boat you know I've been putting out the
album of the day that's the album I
listen to that
day you know play I had to go with
master reality today it was too cloudy
it was just a master reality type of day
plus I drew a rocketship for my daughter
oh yeah me draw every day and I drew the
rocketship and as I was drawing the
rocketship I was singing the lyrics of
into the void and she said dad what are
you saying
and I just kept doing the lyrics like
like I had like a spirit come out with
me and I'm saying
rocket engine burning fuel so fast up
into the night sky they last all that
[ __ ] burning metal through the
atmosphere she was losing it she thought
I was speaking at [ __ ] tongues but
hey that's what it you know all these
little things what it's been good for me
it's made my family a little tighter
first two weeks I wanted to kill him now
we're gonna make it there was one night
there I thought I was only gonna rested
for domestic violence cuz uh you know it
just it was hard for everybody at first
but uh you know me and my wife are
[ __ ] definitely cooler since this so
it's uh it's there's been pros and cons
dean del rey you know well as you start
to go crazy you know we're alive so I'm
gonna enjoy some of the things in life I
love I've been reading books many jokes
nineteen me too I'm almost finished the
Led Zeppelin book yeah I'm deep in the
books man and and you know what I'm
sitting there going like yeah I'm diggin
this every night around 8:00 I get on
the couch and I rip out the book right
now I read and Bill Kreutzmann the
Jennifer Grateful bad spell called deal
and I'm taking the ride man he's
describing all the acid trips and you
know San Francisco and the early days in
the bang I'm just going this is amazing
I you know like amazing on the pizza
the last 30 years the internet came out
as like SIA books and now I'm loving it
man I'm like I'm gonna burn burn through
this one and then next I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get on to where he must burn us
junkie which I partially read when I was
a teen I'm almost finished Led Zeppelin
and I'm going write the mainland no I
read the man who led Zeppelin I finished
that one the week before this is the
really thick Led Zeppelin book the three
parter I forget the gods no no I read
hammer the gods years ago this is a new
one that came out that it's sort of like
hammer the gods just some more detailed
stuff like that when I'm done with this
when I'm moving on to your man Bon Scott
oh and then someday I'm going a David
Lee Roth's book and then from that you
know I already have them lay it out you
know we got three more weeks so I got
three more book yeah we got to the 28th
people whether you like it or not you
got the label 28th and that's
conservative so you might as well start
reading now I even started taking some
Maya some high school like my daughter
goes on this thing and it goes all the
way up to high school like online and I
went to my senior year I went to like
[ __ ] that you go over in 12th grade
you know like reviews and math and
calculus and all that [ __ ] I was like
Jesus Christ I was a dumb [ __ ] at 18 but
I'm trying to do everything I can to
stay busy number one is to happiness
what's that Joey goes that not to be TV
show Joey goes back to high school
oh my god [ __ ] tremendous I can't
even say God [ __ ] you know I know my
time all that [ __ ] the history stuff I'm
weekend yeah but this this is just the
time for them listen I feel bad because
people going through some hardships and
I'm not talking about just staying it
like
staying in should be bad enough of a
punishment then there's the hardship of
no money
you know people running out of money
living off credit cards nobody's working
you got people who are natural hustlers
that for a guy like me this cut my legs
off for two weeks I didn't know what to
do with myself
you know the nervous breakdown I had
Wednesday night was about stand-up I
realized that stand-up was my religion
see and it took me as a man
it took me as a boy I was a kid and I
turned me into a man it really did
because to become a comedian there's
aspect you have to become a man you
really gotta look in the mirror and say
this is what needs to be done that's it
and I was thinking about how it's one
thing to say hey I'm not going down to
the comi
store no more but it's another thing for
them to tell you you can't come down to
Comedy Store no more it's [ __ ] closed
yeah so I had to deal with that all that
fear a few years ago where I was
thinking what if what if the Comedy
Store ever went away I mean it's totally
my my life I love that place and the
people so that's why I started going to
New York because I was thinking if this
place is gone I don't know what I would
do you know so I was like I gotta start
getting out in the world and doing
comedy to where if anything goes away
I'm still relevant I'm not just this one
club now I and my life there and it
really helped me you know I went out
there got past a cellar and stuff and
got all kinds of new New York friends at
the stand and all that and men to not do
comedy it's just blowing my mind right
now you know it's been 20 I guess 24
days since I've been on stage and I just
I can't even believe it it's all I do
all day wait to go on you know yeah it's
been a a month now officially since I
have been on
stage are the emotion similar for you to
because I mean Joey I'm and everyone's
still hustling and working but Joey
you're a little bit more established and
Dean has been putting in work for I
think you just hit your ten-year
anniversary right Dean yeah so you've
been putting in a lot of work and you're
finally starting to see results and then
they take it or like it but it might is
it scary for you Dean or like well how
are you feeling about that
cuz you you literally just switched
everything put ten years aren't working
or finally take it off and then it's
gone
you know when Emily at the store hit me
up to just do that little 30-second
little thing for the comedians give back
I was like it just [ __ ] in as cheesy
as this as it filled my heart man I was
just like oh god they remember me after
you know twenty four days and still I'm
still part of the family and that that
really that and talking to Joey and Ian
Edwards every day member you know I was
just like oh yeah I'm still I'm still
involved in the game and and this is
believe it or not as horrible as this is
it's kind of a force west but I probably
needed and would have never taken you
know such a workaholic so I am feeling
way rejuven eyes as far as like alright
let's get out there you know you know
it's uh it's weird that I reach out to
certain people every day they're the
ones I'm concerned about the most you
know we're not just gonna suffer
financially and a lot of us are gonna
struggle with mental health during this
period you know yeah and like I said
when I went through my thing Wednesday
night the mechanic was on I was having a
great night Charles Bronson was on you
know I was having a great night and
right after the mechanic I wouldn't I
got a notebook and I just thought of
writing living things down and somewhere
I went into a dark place I started
thinking about
and people pipes and [ __ ] I had done
with it as a child and yeah and it just
didn't feel good it didn't feel good all
night and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
and I was sitting in the office and I
said why am i hiding from my wife I need
her now more than ever so I put on my
big boy pants and I sat down next to her
and I told her exactly what I've been
going through the last three weeks
how it came to a head and I tell you
ever since that night I feel 100% better
that's awesome my whole outlook has
changed there's nothing we could do
about it what do you see for the future
with stand-up man that's it that's an
interesting small question Jay somebody
asked me that yesterday and it's a-you
know the whole goal of you and I and the
comedians that are really down at the
still are
it's always about truth and what's going
wrong and life but then you're kind of
like well how do we just step back into
that machine and not just be the virus
the virus the virus the virus so I
started writing down stuff that was more
what was going through my head during
the virus so I don't have to talk about
the Von's
talking about like being a 54 year old
man this [ __ ] in my house that I've
learned since I was 13 years old that
kind of dumb [ __ ] or living in an
apartment and you know and just just
being in East Hollywood no kids nothing
you know just trying to find some kind
of stuff that's going to make sense when
I get back on stage and I really don't
know what it's what it's going to be
like and I think it's a lot like the
first couple of weeks of me doing comedy
back when I started it's going to be
like open mic style because you don't
know what the audio is it going to be an
audience or they're going to be
restriction
we don't really know we don't we don't
and I went on I went on the day before
the comedy store first as the last time
I went on and I remember thinking god
this crowds way too easy right now
because people were say bond and I was
so happy I was making them laugh but you
know when you got that audience where
they're so easy I was like wow just say
don't know when they're laughing
something's not right
yes something's not right now people are
rattled and like man those people are
scared and I am too but it's like when I
got me a motorcycle man leased up and
doing absolutely the last 10 years and
that's all that [ __ ] matters I think
it's I think it's gonna come back slow
at first my heart goes out to a lot of
comics you know a lot of young comics
Lee a lot of guys who started out
they're not gonna have a lot of the
opportunities we had as younger comics
they're gonna have to deal with a lot of
more technology you know let's see how
technology plays to it if there'll be a
lot more pay-per-views nobody [ __ ]
knows and to be honest to you right now
I'm like you I don't really give a
[ __ ] away I just want the guys around
me to keep it together and like
everything else in life this will pass
whether this is a prison sentence that
we will be [ __ ] let out of eventually
and hopefully we'll all get out of this
thing healthy and we could also say what
the [ __ ] was that two years ago you know
yeah what I mean people of all people
trapped some people do better than
others quarantine you know some people
you know this could be a disaster some
people are getting forced to be a
husband
some people get sores to be parents you
know yeah some people are living
learning to live without their parents
you know I feel for those people how
would you like to live in the
neighborhood be your parents and you got
a bang on a glass once a week and like a
[ __ ] gorilla in the zoo I gotta treat
my grandfather now yeah like a [ __ ]
animal pass and peanuts Judith hole in
the puppet and you know I mean that just
uh this is the future that how we're
gonna deal with but any albums you want
to drop on these guys for the week and
you [ __ ] believe how long ago Wow
mainstay was 2002 and Cobain was 94 same
day so I think and I still cannot
believe it and I talked about this
record all the time but I'll shout out
forever mayne Stanley did that solo
record with Mike McCready from Pearl Jam
called a bath you know and that album is
[ __ ] insane man insane and I listened
to today it's all blooming out perfect
Seattle Bob and through that thing on
man you know you got you just got to top
to bottom insane I love it I love it
Mark Lanegan sings on that from the
Screaming Trees and Queens of the Stone
Age he's me and my favorite about the
podcast twice and it's just a
masterpiece record man it's crazy
are you using zoom for your podcast now
well I got very lucky jewelry I had bent
11 episodes before this happened it just
I was just you know brined in and grind
and repaired and gassed over and over
and over and then this happened so I got
him Evan in the can and and I'm just
releasing him once a week and then my
patreon I do a solo bonus moments and
we've done the patriotic Matt's been
rocking a lot of people I mean
way moving I had before I've stepped up
during this during this town for my
patreon channel which is incredible you
know like people people are hurting like
me and they're donating it's it's it's
just unreal man well I'll tell you
what's gonna win in this whole thing the
winner and this whole thing is humanity
you know for years we respected our
soldiers and everything now we're gonna
come out of this respecting a lot more
people soldiers police nurses doctors
you're gonna feel a different way about
those people you know I know for a fact
and if anything you [ __ ] are
listening to me run go get a job in one
of the supermarkets because once this
blows over those that supermarket Union
is gonna sit down and they're gonna be
getting paid thirty thousand dollars a
day
if this happens to ya but it they
deserve it and they deserve every
[ __ ] penny you know and those bus
drivers man the bus drivers all these
guys all these guys have stepped up
these nurses crying and rooms that
breaks my heart because I'm sorry to
tell you you did sign up for that but
you didn't sign up for wearing the same
[ __ ] mask every day right and for
people running in drooling [ __ ] sperm
and with an eyeball out yelling Viva
Corona whatever the [ __ ] they yelling
you know my heart goes out to nurses and
doctors and uh any movies you've been
watching any theories I've been just a
youtube King man it makes me so happy I
was watching today I was watching that
and main Stan Lee they never clear to
that concert at the Moore theater so I
watched that and then of course to the
right corner do you like this maybe
you'll like so dawn right here now and
in a lot of a lot of YouTube man just so
much of it just to come I
can't want any kind of grim stuff it
just it'll make me freak out my
apartment I forced myself to work out in
the afternoons yeah instead of doing it
in the mornings and getting it all
working my testosterone levels are
higher I've been forcing myself to do it
at 4:00 instead of watching the news so
I could how's that it's [ __ ] great
cuz that might do where I have the
punching bag I don't have a big yard
it's just a little corner but the Sun
beats on that corner after 4 o'clock it
becomes like a steam bath in the corner
so I'll set the time of the five minutes
and I'll beat the bag up and after the
first 10 minutes I can feel the sweat
beads coming out of me I could taste of
marijuana and the [ __ ] edibles and
the soft and you know and then I [ __ ]
do another two rounds and I'm [ __ ]
sweaty and then I try to do my
kettlebells but I try to get the sweat
out you know I really want to get that
sodium out and all those Maluku juices
and all that [ __ ] so I got the day
covered you know I could always walk
around the neighbor with the kid no
parks cuz you know everybody with corona
goes to the [ __ ] park so you can't go
to the [ __ ] park
you gotta cover yourself and that's PV
[ __ ] to go with [ __ ] parks day
everybody's walking behind one another
so I got to do alternate planning I
gotta take it on walks with nobody's
gonna be if you go shop and you gotta go
early because there's more the list part
of the day more people have been in
there more germs so you gotta catch
everything at aint no one from 8 to 9
before that greasy [ __ ] at 5 picks
up that gas handle to fill up his gas
tank I'm gonna hit it first I bring my
own [ __ ] I bring handy wipes
we made Puerto Rican [ __ ] Lysol wipes
with alcohol oh yes in gasoline I'm
killing [ __ ] and burning [ __ ] on a
[ __ ] daily but listen man it's always
a [ __ ] pleasure to see you it's
always a pleasure to talk to you every
day thank you for checking in I check in
with you we're real comedy store family
we are dead we are man and I can't
imagine if I didn't do comedy and I was
still like selling motorcycles I just
sit in my box right now with no family
like you guys I'd be like oh [ __ ] this
you know we have hope everybody should
have a little hope this is gonna pass it
may not be three weeks you know don't
get too excited about football I don't
know why that was brought up yesterday
or the day before to make these idiots
[ __ ] think about football now you
know now it's not the time to think
about football anything else at the time
of your future your family and what your
next move is you no more [ __ ]
entrepreneurs are gonna come out of this
than anything people gonna go I can't do
this I want you might as well invent the
[ __ ] Bell you want it to right now
this is the chance to do everything
everything you've ever wanted this is
the chance you know also I really
realized that sitting on this couch all
my life I'm getting the hell out side
I'm gonna go live in life man ya know
that's what else is gonna tell a lot of
people I know people who live in
quarantine for two [ __ ] years already
absolutely now they're seen that they
have to be in quarantine
it's like us would stand up listen I'm
not going to the store for a few weeks
that's a big difference and you can't go
to the store for a few weeks
oh I'm bad so maybe I'll go to the
improv know their [ __ ] clothes cool
you know I'm saying everybody's closed
you wanna [ __ ] yeah they somebody put on
line where's the best open mic I said
the hospital the best open mic right now
you know I'm saying they got full
[ __ ] rooms audience cons the audience
I love you [ __ ]
I'm happy you had the chance to come in
and check in with me brother
yeah this was good yeah you know the
quality sounds good
one the six-month one the six line rule
here's a 10 foot plan yeah it's a it's
really 27 feet if you snorted cocaine
because when you sneeze it travels 27
[ __ ] feet so it's really been quote I
was thinking about them [ __ ]
they have been closed and I'm personal
friends with like three of the waiters
waitresses in there there's one guy
Jesse he just loves the Lakers and my
heart is breaking because they took the
Lakers and the [ __ ] his job so that
pulled baskets off and I'm trying to in
89 an earthquake in San Francisco it
[ __ ] you know wrecked everything and
Danny's had to call us well they are on
24/7 so they never had front door locks
because they were never going to be
closed so they had to go out and buy a
padlock and chains to close the place
they built it with no locks that's crazy
in San Francisco what else they'll steal
your [ __ ] wig with you in it still
you could be walking down the street San
Francisco and I'll send you waiting
disappears then will you up there they
said don't leave nothing in the [ __ ]
car remember that have signs everywhere
they'll break into your car they're not
even Dickinson
not even a [ __ ] 50 we could we had a
walk with the luggage to get lunch yeah
because you gotta take you you got to
think everything in there I love you
buddy
have a great day and check in with us
some time to time [ __ ]
candles lit love you see [ __ ] beam he
does it again my man Dean oh I love Dean
Dell Rhea's he I've been checking in
with him Steve Sam all
CEO Whitney Rogan Tripoli Tiffany
Haddish we've all had a little you know
so I've been checking in with all my
people you know all my [ __ ] family
I've tried some of the other guys they
don't want to call back so they can all
suck my dick you don't call back go [ __ ]
yourself then I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't need you either your greasy stupid
[ __ ] looking for attention all
right it doesn't end it doesn't end
anyway I want to thank you guys for
listening today and I hope you got
something good out of this it's Monday
we're still ticking you're gonna take a
[ __ ] bomb to stop me most importantly
I want to thank you guys hey we tried
the zoom I don't know if it's gonna work
for you
once this [ __ ] [ __ ] goes away
once god cleans this [ __ ] half you
know me will be back on point like
always before I don't [ __ ] around with
you [ __ ] I love you to death
I'm just hitting you have to tell you
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
make it through this this is just
temporary this ain't gonna be around
forever I ain't going [ __ ] nowhere I
was scared for a couple days
[ __ ] these [ __ ] I'm from Jersey [ __ ]
I swam and he's [ __ ] corrosive waters
years ago I'm done I stepped on a
syringe I'm prepared I'm prepared I love
you [ __ ] have a great day I
want to thank my bookie Dodd AG and I
want to thank CBD line com
have a great day kick this [ __ ]
melee
[Music]